[Musique]
cenon rive est reconnu pour avoir des
étiages sévères autant en été qu'en
hiver les niveaux sont bas la rivière
qui est large donc les dépenses hors
d'eau sont très faibles
la rivière nicolet en plein centre du
québec rural
comme partout ailleurs au pays la
sécheresse de l'été 2021 a eu ses effets
ici cette année c'est incroyable en fait
on a vu des niveaux bas record on
n'avait jamais observées çà
est ce que c'est la nouvelle réalité est
ce que ça peu sempéré aussi est-ce que
ça va revenir à la normale
mais qu'est ce que le débit normal pour
cette rivière qui approvisionne en eau
plusieurs villes villages et autres
entreprises agricoles
si difficile à croire mais on a peu de
connaissances sur les quantités d'eau
consommés au québec seuls les très
grands préleveur ceux qui puisent 75
mètres cubes d'eau par jour doivent
détenir un certificat d'utilisation
d'eau c'est le cas par exemple des
municipalités on connaît le point de vue
purement théorique les principaux
usagers on connaît où sont installés la
plupart des puits de surface les puits
d'eau souterraine on connaît les points
de prélèvement pour les grandes
industries les muncipalités mais c'est
l'ensemble
l'addition de tous ces prélèvements
alors qu'on ne connaît pas
j'ai aucune idée quelle est vraiment la
portion naturel qui colle dans ce cours
d'eau là
le chercheur alain rousseau tente
d'établir un vrai portrait comptabilisé
de l'utilisation de l'eau de la rivière
nicolet
c'est une première au québec pour
vraiment savoir la quantité d'eau
prélevés il faudrait avoir des compteurs
d'eau en tout point prélèvements
aussi longtemps qu'on n'aura pas un
portrait clair des prélèvements
cumulatif sur les débits en rivière on
ne pourra pas faire une gestion dite
préventive pour se prémunir et se
préparer aux changements climatiques qui
vont augmenter les pressions sur la
ressource en eau
la météo le climat vont provoquer en
fait des sécheresses comme ça puis si on
continue à utiliser
puis à se développer la même façon mais
à un moment donné va avoir un conflit
le canada possède environ 20% des
réserves mondiales d'eau douce
de ce nombre trois pour cent se trouvent
au québec c'est donc normal de croire à
l'abondance de la ressource quand on
voit le nombre de lacs et rivières et
surtout le fleuve saint laurent tant et
aussi longtemps qu'on n'est pas
confronté à des problèmes aigus en
général on ne sait pas grand chose
moi j'ai souvent l'abondance est général
mais il à orthez locale c'est à dire que
ça donne rien dans une communauté où un
individu de savoir que terre capitaux il
ya énormément d'eau au québec si tu en
as pas le calme
l'australie on a pris quatre mois
consécutifs quand on a eu des manques
d'eau
robert bourdeau et agriculteurs dans le
sud de la montérégie pour lui la
sécheresse de l'été 2021 a été un dur
réveil on a vu les rivières asséchées on
pourra toujours aller pomper des
rivières et lausanne et les rivières et
son ch depuis le début a ou fac aucune
façon d'aller s'approvisionner de l'eau
nulle part rapport les puis
[Musique]
j'ai vu le fond du puits avec du sable
ou parce que je me suis retrouvé à
pomper plus d'eau que j'étais capable
c'est déjà arrivé par des anneaux pas
rêver mais on veut jamais que ça arrive
le sud de la montérégie si le jardin du
québec le coeur de la grande production
maraîchère une agriculture qui a besoin
de beaucoup d'eau mais ici l'eau n'est
pas abondante s'il n'y a pas de pluie on
doit se tourner vers l'eau souterraine
car le débit des rivières est faible
l'impression sur la ressource en eau est
donc importante un nombre vraiment
important de d'utilisateurs une citation
utilisation évidemment municipal de
sudation de résidentiel une situation
agricole puis aussi des prélèvements
industriels qui sont un portable
[Musique]
le chercheur rené lefebvre a analysé les
données d'utilisation de l'eau en lien
avec les réserves d'eau souterraines
disponibles
son constat est clair le sud de la
montérégie fait face à un grand défi
les projections nous disent que on peut
pas poursuivre dans cette voie là au
niveau de la quantité
de l'usaj qu'on fait la ressource qui
est limité pour pour soutenir des
développements a pu finir qu'ils soient
démographique urbains et agricoles il va
falloir faire des choix
de l'autre côté du fleuve à lanoraie
même constat
l'usagé de l'eau est trop grand pour ce
que la ressource peut offrir
l'enjeu c'est la protection d'une
tourbière
ce milieu humide est entouré de terres
agricoles qui servent entre autres à la
production de pommes de terre grande
consommatrice d'eau au moment où on a
commencé à faire de l'agriculture
industrialisée dans la région qu'on a
modifié le cycle et d'euro logique et
donc ça a modifié la porte d'aude
l'hydrologue marie laroque étudie
l'utilisation de l'eau par l'agriculture
et son impact sur cette tourbière on a
vu au fil des années les armes
progresser au sein de la tourbière à
mesure que les espèces ligneuses se met
en place et un cercle vicieux qui
s'installe et plus qu'il ya des espèces
ligneuses plus que les niveaux obèses
plus que le niveau baisse plus que des
espèces ligneuses et là ça progresse
pendant très longtemps le québec a
drainé ses terres et assécher ses
milieux humides pour faire place à de
l'agriculture l'eau on ne voulait pas
qu'elle reste
c'est ce qui s'est passé en montérégie
et c'est ce qui est en train de se
produire à lanoraie
et ça on veut le stopper car on connaît
aujourd'hui les bienfaits hydrologiques
de ces milieux tous les milieux humides
vont ralentir l'eau et faire en sorte
qu'on va maintenir de l'eau à la surface
plus longtemps
quand il y en a beaucoup quand une
grande matrice de milieux humides sur un
territoire on a cet effet tampon de
retenir les eaux lors des crues de
relâcher l'eau lors des étiages
on draine les tourbières on coupe les
armes ont fait défaut c'est ont
construit des routes il ya de
l'étalement urbain donc on a de moins en
moins cette réserve d'eau leur surface
et c'est crucial pour nous au québec
devant ce constat selon l'hydrologue
marie laroque il faut évaluer toutes les
pistes de solutions possibles ta tête
comptent pour aller chercher de l'eau
d'une source aussi faire venir de l'eau
du fleuve pour l'irrigation
évidemment il ya des coups qui sont
importants mais il ya des enjeux de
disponibilité de l'eau des enjeux
sociaux aussi est-ce qu'on veut passer
un pipeline dans une région
il ya pas de réponse 5 parfaite mais on
sait qu'il faut qu'il y ait des
changements si on veut maintenir le mode
de vie des agriculteurs tout en
protégeant le milieu humide
ces
deux lacs artificiels en montérégie
robert bourdeau n'a plus le choix il
doit investir dans la rétention de l'eau
aux 20,6 enregistrée comme l'âge et
commencer à magasiner de l'eau qu'est ce
que je fais à pau avait quelqu'un qui
arrive une sécheresse étendue trop tard
pour commencer a dit on prend lyon où ça
va être de la magazine et au fond des
neiges pour en avoir pour les trains
depuis les dernières années le québec
qui rattrape un retard dans sa
connaissance de ses ressources en eau
potable
ces travaux ont permis de comprendre que
malgré une image d'abondance en eau les
risques de pénurie sont bien réels et
que la ressource en eau qu'elle soit en
rivière ou sous terre ne fait qu'une
l'eau c'est une ressource unique qu'elle
soit souterraines ou de surface parce
que l'eau souterraine fini son parcours
dans les cours d'eau si aux jo qui colle
dans les cours d'eau c'est parce qu'ils
sont alimentés par l'eau souterraine à
quelque part en amont mais quand on est
rendu au mois d'août l'eau qui est dans
la rivière c'est le terrain
essentiellement
[Musique]
que ce soit au québec en alberta en
colombie-britannique où ailleurs au pays
l'eau est vitale
tant pour les citoyens que pour
l'économie
et pour en assurer la saine gestion on
doit viser les mêmes objectifs réduction
de la consommation utilisation plus
précise et surtout partage de la
ressource
nous n'avons pas une approche commune de
gestion
pourtant notre eau provient des
précipitations qui n'ont pas de
frontières
nous partageons lot des grands lacs nous
partageons notre eau mais nous ne
partageons pas la responsabilité de la
gestion de notre seigneur winch est
responsable manager
[Musique]
l'exportation massive ou le transport
massif d'eau ça se fait peur c'est hors
de prix c'est pour ce que ça prend de
l'eau lequel ne puis locon aux locales
mais bon il faut la gérer pour garder
c'est kate ips quantité
la communauté scientifique s'est depuis
plusieurs années qu'il y à une crise de
l'eau au canada parce que nous n'avons
pas bien géré la ressource
pays qui possède 20% de l'eau douce
mondiale ne devrait pas avoir une crise
de dubai world
[Musique]